[Music]
to get fat I mean to you you're looking
for exceptions rather than the rule like
you're looking for the exception most
people are fat because they eat too much
and don't exercise you have to eat too
and so you're right and so when I say
what I was talking about in that post
was leaving the whales so if a girl I
was talking about if you if a girl gets
a ring okay and then she's 120 and she
decides to gain 100 pounds to 220. I
said leave the whale because I'm sorry
you you made the choice to gain 100
pounds that's disrespectful to your
husband and you know you you can
disagree with calling her a whale but
like what else are you gonna call her
that's
it's a big woman